cleanup continues for residents in the
lake sahara apartments in fact this is
video showing the storm damage caused
last month now nearly two weeks later
there's still more to do victoria saha
joins us live from that complex after
hearing from people living there
yes denise it looks like there's still a
lot of work that still needs to be done
from that storm damage and take a look
over here big pieces of trees still just
hanging out in the courtyard waiting to
be moved and a lot of these apartments
still have signs asking residents to not
enter
the damage that monsoon season brings
could be unpredictable
but seeing what's left from the july
storms shows us just how strong mother
nature could be we walked around the
lake sahara apartments and saw work that
is still being done to clear out the
damage i think i counted
eight trees totaled it were down on the
property william salazar lives at the
lake sahara apartments he says he was
one of 16 families that had to be
evacuated after a tree fell onto his
building after
leaving here we went to
motel 6 stayed there for a couple of
nights and then one of our friends from
work
our co-worker he
let us come over to his house and bring
our animals he says he didn't know when
he would be allowed to live in his
apartment again but came back to empty
out his fridge since the power was
turned off all in all
with me my wife and our roommate we have
spent close to two thousand dollars
with
the amount that you know just taking
care of
business and feeding everybody and as
monsoon season continues to keep us on
the edge salazar says living in the top
floor has become a worry for him there's
been no end to the stress we've just you
know one blow after another take it day
by day
just recently we did actually get an
update from salazar he said that his
power was finally back on nearly after
two weeks so he was allowed to move back
to his apartment today i did reach out
to the apartment complex to find out how
many residents are still without their
home but i'm still waiting to hear back
victoria zaha live local now